das
als nächstes morgen kann ich sich machen also heißt am wochenende höchstwahrscheinlich
ich hoffe mal samstag samstag ist immer ein ganz guter tag für neue bits heute machen wir
keinen körpernätis nee aber gar nichts ich habe heute ein bisschen so wie der körpernätis gebastelt
ich habe mal versucht ein gitlab zu hausen den körpernätis leute ich sage euch das ist abfakt
ist selbst hausen ich weiß schon warum man sowas normalerweise nicht selbst hausen will
ich weiß ich an mir liegt es nicht in dem fall liegt es nicht an mir bei
letzten videos hat es immer an mir gelegen
kurz gucken ob heute noch irgendwie kreisel grind mmo ist aber die waren bis jetzt alle
nicht da deswegen vermute ich mal nicht
nee nix kein kreisel grind
heute ist wirklich du findest gettler mittlerweile für still ich weiß gar nicht ich kann dazu nicht
viel sagen ich habe gettler selbst ewig nicht benutzt aber ich dachte mir so hey warum warum
hauen wir nicht einfach mal in meinen lokalen körpernätis cluster gettler helm install gettler
rein und das ist im prinzip auch einfach leider funktioniert wieder ein paar sachen nicht und
das ist ewig abfaktes rauszukriegen ja zum beispiel zum beispiel ist da standard runner container
er backt und du musst erst mal paar helm chart werte überschreiben dass der mit dem ubuntu
image und ich bin im elpein image startet weil das elpein image hat dns auflösungsprobleme
da gab es witzigerweise erst vor kurzem ein hacker news elpein post
never use again oder sowas hieß das i will never use again elpein linux und das war mir so auch gar
nicht klar elpein hat probleme wenn dns anfragen größer als 512 byte sind also bzw dns request
größer sind als 512 byte der gesamte request nicht nur die anfrage und da muss man sagen das
wusste ich nicht und das ist ziemlich scheiße weil je nachdem was so einen dns server return kann
man durchaus schon mal über 512 byte kommen ich mein wenn das ding erst mal mx record vier weitere
server und hast du nicht gesehen returned dann gibt es auf einmal dns problemen von denen man
nichts wusste und jetzt hat lustigerweise der gettler runner auch probleme gehabt den ich
installiert habe mit elpein linux und dann geht es weiter dann funktioniert beim runner natürlich
kein docker in docker weil es ist ja quasi schon ein containerisierter workload und sowas
es ist alles ist alles ein bisschen eklig ich wollte mal so ein komplettes system drauf klatschen
ich dachte mir die haben so einen helm chart zum installieren haust du mal drauf ist ist
tatsächlich unglaublich bescheuert gemacht also ja es ist wieder viel viel zu kompliziert
nee heute kein kubernetes stellt das das kriege ich heute nicht noch nicht auf die
reihe ich habe tagsüber ein bisschen bisschen kubernetes gestellt und da habe ich jetzt
keinen bock drauf mehr ich mal gucken ich meine realistisch ist es ähnlich warum sollte man
in dem kubernetes cluster selbst haus macht ja eigentlich jetzt relativ wenig sinn
gettler entwickelt sich auch super langsam bei den sind issues 2 ja gut das ist aber normal bei
größeren projekten die kriegen ja tausende issues oder hunderte issues kannst du gar nicht
alle fixen und kennt ihr kennt ihr so gettler wenn ich gettler gettler projekte was ist denn
mit der musik wieder los mit ihr zweimal so laut ich brauche was ich brauche relaxing hier das da
jetzt ja besser kennt ihr kennt ihr größere open source oder generelle guitar projekte es wird es
wird dann youtube geschaut ja oder zumindest teilweise brutal downfall auf ach er wieder
der hat der hat schon lange kein von dem aber schon lange nichts mehr geguckt ja was ich sagen
wollte kennt ihr die guitar projekte die so einen automatischen ich schließe das issue bot
drinnen haben das ist das unsinnigste überhaupt und dass das fackt mich jedes mal ab du suchst
nach irgendeinem fehler findest was über google stellst fest oh das ist sogar ein ticket schon
offen in dem in dem projekt was verpackt ist guckst rein autoclose nach 30 tagen nichts wurde gemacht
nichts wurde reagiert es ist so hängen geblieben deswegen mache ich das deswegen mache ich das
auch nicht der fiat champ wird issues aufhaben bis 2045 wenn es keinen mehr interessiert ich
werde den kram nur klausen von hand oder halt fixen wobei ich gerade kein bock habe
ja autoclose nach 30 tagen ist richtig richtig blöd ne machen wir heute gar nicht heute gucken
wir ein bisschen heute schwätzt mal ein bisschen gucken paar videos ist ja nur noch quasi fast
knapp zwei stunden zeit ja aber das finde ich total bescheuert die autoclose geschichte
der manche machen docker in docker im runner funktioniert ja aber das funktioniert nicht
so ohne weiteres wenn dein runner in dem kubernetes cluster läuft wenn ein runner im kubernetes
cluster läuft musst du als erstens den container privileged ausführen und dann irgendwelche
environment variablen setzen und das hat bei mir nicht funktioniert wobei es eigentlich eine
ziemlich doofe idee ist den privileged container im kubernetes cluster auszuführen und da irgendwie
docker zeug freizugeben ich weiß nicht was das bedeutet für zugriff auf den kubernetes cluster
selbst das klingt zumindest nicht nach einer guten idee da kann er dann jeder die kubernetes cluster
ausschalten oder so das klingt nicht so sinnig ich muss auch sagen ich finde es nicht ich finde
es gar nicht mal großartig sinnvoll ja wie habt ihr das gemacht ja moment ihr baut im er sie baut
docker images in kubernetes ja gut ich will bilden das da will ich machen also wie gesagt also
geht lab selbst braucht sagt also geht lab selbst sagt man muss den container privileged starten
und irgendwie zugriff auf den cluster geben was irgendwie an sich schon ziemlich komisch ist
ach so docker in docker ja docker in docker funktioniert das ist das ist keine ahnung weiß
ich was ist das kenne ich nicht aber ich will das ja gar nicht wirklich machen ich wollte es ja
heute noch mal ausprobieren weil an sich finde ich ziemlich unsinnig ehrlich gesagt das hast du
nämlich irgendwie so ein hennei problem also wenn du alles in einem cluster über irgendeinen git
repo laufen lässt was dann selbst wiederum im kubernetes cluster gehostet ist und mal irgendwas
geht kaputt dann ist das repo nicht da du kannst keine änderungen machen das ist alles ein bisschen
unsinnig also wenn schon sollte es ein extra cluster sein oder ganz ehrlich nehmt einfach
in den gehosteten service und gut ist wenn man eh schon in der cloud unterwegs ist warum sollte
ich den graben selbst hosten wenn es was fertiges gibt und man hat sich und man hat sich schon
dafür entschieden dass man cloud services benutzt wenn alles offline machen will ganz ehrlich dann
würde ich schlicht und ergreifend eine vm hinhauen und gut ist dass das unabhängig davon ist weil
den cluster managen über ein system was selbst im cluster läuft ist immer ein bisschen wie sie
doof außerdem finde ich also außerdem muss ich sagen war es ziemlich kompliziert bisher
was sind gute weiterbildung für fang informatiker system was man so viel fang informatiker system
integrations azubis also integration wird zwar mit i geschrieben aber trotzdem kommt darauf an was
dich interessiert was interessiert dich denn sag mal was dich für einen bereich interessiert
kann man pauschal nicht sagen man du kannst alles und nichts machen
nee war ich nicht ist das irgendein
vor er ding oder mal das extra remake von resident evil 4 oder die xc neuauflage
das drama habe ich übrigens auch nur am rande mitbekommen um getter oder getti oder getti
das ausspricht die wurden von irgendeinem von irgendeiner firma in hongkong nicht übernommen
sondern irgendeine hongkonger china chinesen firma will jetzt support dafür anbieten oder so was es
gab einen riesigen shitstorm sein riesigen shitstorm ist vielleicht übertrieben nicht zu ver nicht
nicht zu verwechseln oder zu vergleichen mit dem wizard game shitstorm das hat deutlich mehr
leute interessiert als dass wenn leute irgendwas forken und jetzt gibt es irgendwie einen fork
der weiterhin der wird von krautberg entwickelt kein schimmer was da wieder abgeht man wenn
der friseur wieder bock hat kannst du seht und regex gut ja geht ganz gut ja seht synthax ist
aber abartig und du kannst auch nicht alle regex schweinereien in seht machen
welche gab es wieder neue ich kenne nur die fortgen leaks
dass es wieder dass es in der zeit 2020 bis 2030 spielen soll und also dass es nicht mehr
ganz so futuristisch ist dass es wieder ein single player haben soll und weiß ich gar ja
genau genau battle royale zum start ja mal gucken ganz ehrlich fortgen leaks haben ja schon ab und
zu mal gestimmt kann durchaus sein klingt auch sinnvoll ich mein gerade das mit dem battle royale
modus für bettel viel sieben klinken sofern sinnvoll weil der neue battlefield chef ja der
von apex legends ist und er hat halt erfahrung mit battle royales und die leute haben schon lange
nach dem battle royale geschrien zumal war zone 2 nicht so gut läuft wie es sein könnte vielleicht
haben sie die hoffnung so aus diesem modern warfare military bereich ein paar leute abzugreifen und das
könnte durchaus klappen also wenn das gescheit ist ich trau halt da ist nicht mehr zu dass was
gescheites machen 128 spieler battle royale das würde ich durchaus verstehen das klingt irgendwie
so nicht je nach karte aber normale spielmodi weiß ich nicht ob 128 nicht so sinnvoll ist das
hängt aber auch ein bisschen von den karten ab und wie die spotting mechanik und alles funktioniert
im battlefields 2042 ist es ja aktuell so dass dich dass sich irgendwie jeder daher gelaufen
und gut irgendwie spotten kann dann ist natürlich schwierig wenn du 64 spieler hast die auf dich
gucken können potenziell habt ihr vorschläge wie man sein eigenes bios pricken kann für
ein notebook auf das man wut hat da gibt es was viel einfacheres selten von so was also wenn
du notebook kaputt machen willst dann kannst du richtig kaputt machen dann machst du richtig
kaputt warum willst du das bios pricken das bringt das wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren
das wird wahrscheinlich also wenn das ein halbwegs gescheites notebook ist wird das wahrscheinlich
nicht funktionieren muss was mit geprägtem bios anfangen ich check mich was los ist es
schon geprägt oder willst du es pricken da gibt es jetzt das ist unverständlich
du willst es pricken ja du willst ein notebook kaputt machen warum haust du es nicht kaputt
also ich meine ich könnte mir einfache varianten vorstellen ein notebook zu zerstören als das bios
zu pricken oder hat es irgendeinen grund warum du ausgerechnet das bios pricken willst und nicht
das ding kaputt machen kannst du aber abgesehen dass es wahrscheinlich gar kein bios mehr ist
also wie gesagt forst power off wird nicht wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren es kann nicht
so einfach in bios zu pricken vielleicht kannst du im bios feilen mit dem hexeditor
rumsauen und das dann flaschen falls er keinen checksum der überprüfung macht oder sowas
tja dann fällt mir das so spontan auch nichts ein die dinger sind ja absichtlich so gemacht
dass man sie relativ relativ schwer pricken kann weil sonst das notebook nicht verbutet
tja nee keine ahnung fällt jetzt nichts ein die leute sind einfach nicht mehr da ich verstehe
es auch nicht warum sie es nicht gebacken kriegen nein das wird bei den meisten nichts nichts bringen
großartig strom rausziehen das steht zwar immer da achtung bitte nicht den strom abschalten aber
bei den meisten passiert dann gar nichts das ist eine gute frage da kann ich mal meinen
senf zu geben auch wenn ich noch nicht alle cloud cloud plattform wirklich jetzt so ausführlich
benutzt habe also ich kenne mich mit azure am besten aus ach moment ich habe mich ver ich
habe mich verlesen ich habe mich verlesen ich habe ich habe gelesen azure aws oder gcp ich
habe mich für ich habe mich verlesen ich dachte du willst wissen was die unter zwischen welche
cloud plattform ich am besten finde nee ok du willst wissen würdet ihr für infrastructure
bei aws eher terraform oder cdk nutzen oder doch ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung ich kenne ich kenne
das amazon eigene zeug nicht ich habe das noch nicht verwendet ich würde allerdings
persönlich eher zu terraform tendieren weil du mit terraform auch andere sachen machen
kannst und ich so sehr an diesen an diesen ein cloud anbieter gebunden bist und da lernst du
halt auch was für die zukunft ja klar mein du kannst sagen cdk lernst auch was für die zukunft
aber die zukunft heißt dann auf jeden fall aws also ich ich würde mir auf jeden fall terraform
angucken und ich würde wahrscheinlich terraform auch vorziehen das liegt aber daran weil ich auch
mit anderen cloud plattform als aws was machen will mit aws mache ich eigentlich am wenigsten
aws blick ich immer nicht durch wie die einzelnen dinge heißen die haben ein fahre gate und so was
was soll fahre gate sein fahre gate ist glaube ich der managed kubernetes service von von amazon
und so dinge die haben namen da blickste überhaupt nicht durch ne da blickt auch aws nicht durch
also die benahmungen sind bei google cloud habe ich jetzt gesehen ich habe mich jetzt in letzter
zeit öfters mittel mit google cloud beschäftigt da geht es zum größten teil ja also die die
dinge heißen dann auch hostet rdb oder irgendwie so was und also da muss ich sagen das teuch bei
google ist eigentlich ganz sinnvoll benannt bei azure geht es auch einigermaßen
das kann sein ich weiß es aus dem kopf nicht aber es ist es ist auf jeden fall wirbel das
teuch bei amazon benannt ist da blick ich da blick ich nicht durch so das muss ich sagen ich
habe auch schon ein bisschen in letzter zeit mit polumi rumgespielt wenn ich persönlich viel
angenehme als terraform ich bin aber zumindest froh dass terraform kein jammel verwenden wobei
kann terraform nicht sogar mittlerweile jammel anscheinend können die auch jammel mittlerweile
also ich bin ja ich bin ja eigentlich ganz froh dass das terraform kein jammel verwendet
weil jammel geht mir auch in letzter zeit zunehmend auf den sack man ist ja bald kein
devops engineer mehr oder kein anwendungsentwickler mehr oder keinen admin mehr sondern ist eher
jammel engineer weil alles mittlerweile nur noch in jammel ist und jammel ist so kacke zu lesen und
jammel ist so verbose das ist so lang alles du schreibst alles 30 mal hin und ich bin kein
großartiger jammelfan ja gut du kannst es manchmal nicht aussuchen ja wenn du halt tools verwendest
die jammel konfig haben dann ist jammel konfig das einzige was du machen kannst und selbst wenn
nicht selbst wenn es dafür dann irgendwelche tommel möglichkeiten gibt es halt die frage
wieder ob das irgendwas community maintained ist ist wo dann morgen kein support mehr gibt
ist das irgendwas was die auch die anderen verstehen wenn man mit diesem service nur jammel
gewöhnt ist also eins muss ich sagen eins habe ich die letzten jahre über gelernt es ist sinnvoll
sich an die falls zu halten beziehungsweise so wenig wie nötig von den defaults abzuweichen
einfach der klarheit halber
und nachdem das manchmal
so kompliziert werden kann alles was man macht ist es sinnvoll wenn man bei defaults bleibt wenn
möglich dann hast du auch nicht das problem dass du irgendwie ein custom plugin brauchst von
irgendeinem party typ der dann in zwei monaten keinen bock mehr hat weil wenn man sich mal
anguckt wie zusammengestücke manche manche services mittlerweile sind die bestehen aus 180
verschiedenen einzelteilen und produkten und alles lässt sich ein bisschen anders konfigurieren und
da bin ich mittlerweile auf dem standpunkt dass ich sage manchmal ist es sogar sinnvoll vielleicht
auf ein bisschen funktionalität zu verzichten wenn man es halt nicht zwingend braucht und lieber
bei dem default zu bleiben und das was mitgeliefert wird als noch drei zusätzliche plugins die noch
mal extra konfiguriert werden müssen das ist richtig wie gesagt ich mir das auch gut gefallen
also ich persönlich würde wenn ich die auswahl habe die sachen auch lieber in polumi machen
als in terraform das stimmt terraform lässt sich nicht eins zu eins transferieren jeder prob
also alles sieht anders aus vor allem liegt halt auch daran weil die dinger unterschiedlich heißen
es heißt halt bei aws anders als bei azure oder bei gcp dann heißt das halt auch in terraform
anders weil die cloud anbieter den kram unterschiedlich binden ja gut ist halt so
aber man kann sich zumindest dran gewöhnen wie man terraform an sich verwendet von der
sündachs her wie man schleifen macht und so was man schleifen man weiß auch immer die sich da
ausgedacht haben aber meine augen ja kauen wenn ich das hier schon sehe man was zum tollen da
genauso eklig wie schleifen in anzippen wobei es da mittlerweile möglichkeiten gibt
guckt euch guckt euch das mal an
hallo wie wäre es einfach mal mit dem beispiel
count ja das ist das ist doch eklig wenn man sich da ausgedacht man kann irgendwie neowimp
das muss man auch noch machen ja wahrscheinlich also morgen gar nichts also wobei morgen bin
ich arbeiten und dann abends wahrscheinlich kreise kreint wochen muss ich die video machen
da man ein bisschen kubernetes stellt mal gucken weil wir das mit neowimp machen
mir ist eine sache letztens aufgefallen was an anzippen kacke ist im verbleib im vergleich zu
puppet wir haben ja bei mir auf der arbeit relativ viel puppet noch weil weil da da seit
keine ahnung über zehn jahren dran rum gewurstet gewurstet wird da gab es noch kein anzippen und
puppet hat ein schönes feature man kann sagen also server konfiguration sowohl in anzippen
als auch in puppet kann man zum beispiel definieren dieser server braucht den user max mit berechtigung
auf verzeichnissen und so was kann man in beiden tools konfigurieren ist kein problem aber in
puppet kann man sagen puppet run nur ob und dann zeigt er einem an was er machen würde das
geht in anzippen zwar theoretisch auch mit glaubt wie heißt das testmode bei anzippen ist es aber so
dass testmode nicht so schön anzeigt also was er jetzt genau machen würde und das testmode
optional ist also testmode ist nichts was anzippen direkt unterstützt sondern was was die unterschiedlichen
provider und module unterstützen müssen also da muss ich sagen da finde ich das wie es puppet
gemacht hat immer noch schicker dafür finde ich anzippen viel einfacher zu zu handhaben als puppet
frage als informatiker zu ich würde gerne ein wenig mehr in die welt von lindungs einschalten
hat er bisher nur wenig berührungspunkt das gute tipp für den einstieg in die lindungswelt bei uns
ja gut dann ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig auf der arbeit in kontakt mit
linux zu kommen wenn die nur windows verwenden da bleibt dir nix übrig für dich privat ein
bisschen damit zu beschäftigen oder aber vielleicht gibt es ja tatsächlich die möglichkeit dass du
was auf der arbeit machst was irgendwie auch für die für den arbeitgeber von mehrwert ist
fällt mir jetzt spontan ehrlich gesagt nix ein man könnte ja microsoft sql auf linux hosten du
willst lachen also das funktioniert ja das geht das ist mittlerweile offiziell supportet aber ich
wüsste nicht warum man das machen sollte wenn man außer man sich das massochistisch veranlagt
du kannst dich natürlich privat damit beschäftigen das kann den installierst du dir eine vm installierst
der vm oder virtual box oder sonst was und dann installierst du dir neben deiner linux kiste
erleben an der windows kiste installierst du dir eine linux kiste einer vm und kannst rumwurscht
kein kubanides cluster installieren war leute empfehlen den leuten nicht so komische dinger
die haben er hat kein linux know-how die leute dort in die firma auch kein linux
know-how warum sollen die sich die eigenen kubanides cluster installieren
na gut vielleicht ist es auch die taktik ihr wollt dass die firma pleite geht weil sie nur windows
verwendet sonst machst du hier eine vm linux drauf gut ist ich lösche das mal und da kannst
hier ein bisschen mit rum basteln du kannst dir natürlich auch irgendwelche cloud vms mieten
und sowas wobei ich ehrlich gesagt sagen wird nimm nichts was im internet hängt sondern probier
lokal aus und ich finde ja persönlich das ist die beste variante was du machen kannst wenn du
eine linux nee du kannst auch ein raspberry pi holen aber raspberry pi sind aktuell zu teuer
also ich finde es am sinnvollsten du setzt dich erst einmal ganz normal mit linux auseinander in
form von irgendeiner installation in der vm mit grafischem interface und arbeitest ein bisschen
so mit linux da wo es da wo es halt geht so mache ich das ja auch ich habe meine vm auf
dem zweiten desktop und ich mache alles was nicht unbedingt unter linux gemacht werden muss in
meiner linux vm und da lernt man schon einiges dabei einfach wenn er das tagtäglich benutzt
du lernst was wo man bestimmte pakete konfiguriert so wie man kommando zeilen sachen händelt und
sowas das das lernt man wahrscheinlich im täglichen umgang als desktop distribution wo man halt drauf
arbeitet und auch täglich benutzt besser als ich ab und zu mal per ssh auf dem server einloggen und
da ein bisschen rum basteln also würde ich machen ganz ehrlich ich würde gar nicht mit
serveranwendungen anfangen auch wenn das vielleicht dein ziel ist in zukunft dass du sagst du willst
noch mal linux server administrieren aber du brauchst erstmal linux grundlagen und linux grundlagen
heißt unter anderem kommando zeilen lernen und generell so ein bisschen linux linux so feeling
und und kenntnisse aufbauen und da ist tatsächlich das beste man verwende das tagtäglich das heißt
macht in linux vm hau dir den artschlinux drauf und dann ubuntu wenn er nicht also nehmen ubuntu
oder mint oder sowas zum mint linux zum starten wobei ich ja auch persönlich sagen würde so
ein arten so ein artschlinux install ist auch kein ding weil wenn es geschafft dass jeder dort
ein grafisches environment zu installieren so dass es ganz gut funktioniert hast du schon mal einiges
gelernt wird aber am anfang vielleicht bisschen frustrierend aber das wichtig also wenn du täglich
damit arbeitest lernst du unglaublich viel du lernst mehr als kurse ganz ehrlich kurse bringen
überhaupt nix kurse sind gut um so die so die ganzen begriffe die mit dem thema zu tun haben
aufzuschnappen ich habe mir beispielsweise auch vor ein paar wochen bei judymi so im schnelldurchgang
ein paar kubanete sachen angeguckt und auf youtube damit ich da ein bisschen so ein bisschen wieder
was die basics angeht besser durch durchblicke ich habe das aber total schnell durchgeskippt und
habe mir angeguckt ok ok ich brauche im hinterkopf muss ich mir beispielsweise merken helm charts
anpassen eigenes value file ok ingress controller guck da hier da habe ich ganz schnell durch
durchgemacht innerhalb von einem tag das war irgendwie nur eine stunde einen kurs mit irgendwie
zwölf stunden video laufzeit oder sowas ich habe die videos auf 1,25 prozent geschwindigkeit
gestellt und habe noch die ganze zeit hier feier feiltaste gedrückt nach vorne und dann
hatte ich so ein krumm überblick und dafür sind kurse gut aber ansonsten zum tiefgreifend lernen
musste die kurse machen und gleichzeitig dabei üben oder am besten halt auch tagtäglich verwenden
tagtäglich verwenden ist das best was machen kannst ja mail server mail server ist auch nix
was man eigentlich machen will melz aber es total abartig also wirst auf jeden fall sehr viel
lernen wenn du dir linux system installierst in der vm und das versuchst täglich so für die
meisten sachen die nicht unbedingt windows erfordert oder sagt man mal so muss ja auch
nicht für das meiste machen ja normales internet surfen auf youtube und so das mache ich hier
noch in meiner meiner windows kiste aber so für ein bisschen wenn wenn du was programmierst wenn
du ein bisschen was basteln willst dann macht das unter linux ich würde sagen ich bin so ich bin
tagsüber so ungefähr so 60 prozent in unter linux unter ja ungefähr 60 prozent oder linux
unterwegs ungefähr 40 prozent oder windows unterwegs oder lernst so viel weil du wirst
auf einmal probleme haben wurde dich fragst hey wie konfigurier ich das jetzt da musste gucken
wie du auf der kommando zeile was editierst gucken wo liegt denn die konfig datei und solche
geschichten was ist das oder stellst du zum beispiel fest meine tastatur ist kaputt
und jetzt geht sie wieder nachdem man das terminal neu gestartet hat alles gut
ja so will ich das machen
ich finde jason tatsächlich angenehmer als jammer das stimmt dass jason keine
kommentare unterstützt allerdings neuere versionen oder standards von jason können
ja mittlerweile auch comments
aber das vieles unterstützt das noch gar nicht haben wir letztens erst letztens erst uns angeguckt
also es könnte auch eine extension gewesen sein wo
irgendwer zum standard was dazu gedichtet hat aber ich bilde mir ein in einem der
neueren standards gibt es mittlerweile auch kommentare
meine augen aber das unterstützt noch nicht viele da stimmt
na gut man kann doch unter polumi irgendwie auch terraform provider benutzen oder
das nervige an terraform ist dass man sich selbst um den state kümmern muss
naja irgendwo musst du deinen state doch ablegen das ist eh das beste wenn du terraform also den
state würde ich nie ins git repo oder so einchecken was zum beispiel ganz cool sein muss ist wenn man
das kann ich aus praktischer erfahrung nicht sagen aber wenn ich jetzt noch mal was neu machen würde
mit terraform und was vorschlagen könnte dann würde ich sagen dass man das einfach in
irgendein s3 storage in der cloud mit eincheckt weil dann hast du das auch
ok wie gesagt cdk habe ich schon nie verwendet was die neo will machen will ich will mir mal
angucken wie so das plug in ökosystem ist und wie man das gescheit mit lua konfiguriert ich habe
ja neowin noch nie groß ich hatte das schon eine weile mal installiert ganz am anfang als es noch
neu war das war noch irgendwie 0 1 oder sowas weil die da asynchrones hundagshighlighting und so was
drin hatten war ich ganz cool fand danach habe ich aber aufgehört wim aufzubohren mega krass und
bin hauptsächlich auf wishell studio code und jetbrain idees umgeschwenkt für alles was ich so
mache und benutze wim jetzt tatsächlich nur noch für dinger wie kommando zeilen editieren und
dementsprechend kurz ist meine wim rc auch da ist nichts mehr großartig drinne ich weiß bei
manchen sachen auch gar nicht mehr warum die da überhaupt drinne stehen
übrigens es gibt ein sehr cooles projekt für aws entwickler ich zeige euch das mal
falls ihr das noch nicht kennt ich habe selbst noch nicht verwendet aber ich bin letztens
darüber gestolpert die haben fast alle aws apis nachgebaut so dass man sie lokal verwenden kann
das ist nicht für performance oder so gedacht das ist nur dafür gedacht dass man nicht schon
während der entwicklung 50.000 euro kosten verursacht laufend also du kannst mehr oder
weniger alle aws apis lokal damit verwenden ist auch nicht ganz unbeliebt mit 46.000 stern
ganz das lokal hosten und dann ohne dass du cloud ressourcen brauchst lokal dein kram ausprobieren
und dagegen entwickeln das finde ich klingt sehr nice nur dass ich halt kein aws verwende
normalerweise also keine ahnung wie gut das wirklich ist aber die idee dahinter finde ich
dass man kann auch so sachen wie dynamo db und so was verwenden da wie gesagt die api das heißt
nicht zwangsläufig dass das wirklich auch performant ist wie in der cloud das läuft ja
immer in lokal und ist in python implementiert kann es ja gar nicht sein aber es ist viel
angenehmer gegen was zu entwickeln was lokal ist als wo du laufend dann auch noch geld dafür
bezahlen muss ja beid macht auch kaum noch einer also beid brauchst du an manchen stellen aber in
der regel brauchst du es nicht und meldserver macht auch keiner mehr dabei verstand es selbst
wir haben letztens zum beispiel bisschen kubernetes zeug gebaut machen wir übrigens demnächst auch
weiter sind noch ein paar sachen offen und ich habe mir dann mal so überlegt ok es mal realistisch
betrachtet ich hätte ich hätte irgendeinen managt kubernetes cluster in der cloud was würde ich
darauf laufen lassen und ich würde tatsächlich gucken dass ich nach möglichkeit reine nach
möglichkeit sage ich ja so gut wie nur stateless anwendung drauf laufen lassen alles andere wo
state irgendwie hin muss für über cloud services laufen lassen wenn ich es in der cloud laufen
lassen will wohlgemerkt ja also ich würde die datenbank nicht selber hausten im kubernetes
cluster ich würde irgendwie auch irgendwie man als datenbank benutzen ich würde auch
irgendwelche message cues und sowas nicht im kubernetes hausten sondern in irgendwelche
cloud services dafür verwenden weil man muss sich ja nicht also wenn man sich schon dafür
entschieden hat sachen in der cloud zu verwenden dann muss man sich ja auch nicht unnötig das
leben schwer machen sondern kann das benutzen was angeboten wird wenn es preislich hinhauten alles
kann was man will aber ich mein was soll eine managet postgres in der google cloud nicht können das
ist das stinknormale postgres datenbank nur dass man sich nicht selbst um failover cluster
management master selection und so was darf man das weiß gar ob das auch ob das wort überhaupt
noch ok ist ja master selection kümmern muss und so was ist halt viel angenehmer
hast du was mit dem wireless wire mit dem was dem wireless wire cube sagt mir gar nichts was ist
der wireless wire cube das ist irgendein outdoor access point auf 5g ist out jetzt
sind wir bei 60g schon angelangt keine ahnung wofür man den verwendet nee du benutzt auch
du benutzt auf der arbeit auch eine vm war ich nicht auf der arbeit habe ich
linux auf dem notebook installiert ich habe windows notebook und linux notebook da muss
ich mal gucken ob ich dann meinen neuen arbeitgeber auch dazu bringe mir zwei notebooks zu geben
eins für linux installation und eins mit windows was man für alle firmen interne
geschichten braucht ich könnte allerdings auch ohne probleme mit einer vm leben ob ich
rein mit wsl leben kann weiß ich noch nicht ich wsl das ist immer so ein thema wo alle sagen ja
es funktioniert doch alles und dann weißt du genau im hinterkopf es gab immer mal gewisse
sachen die nicht funktioniert haben in wsl aber es fällt dir dann immer nicht passend ein dazu
ich müsste eigentlich mal eine liste machen mit dingern die in wsl nicht ordentlich funktionieren
weil immer wenn es um die frage geht na was ist es warum geht es warum warum nicht wsl dann sage
ich immer weil nicht alles richtig funktioniert in wsl und dann wollen sie immer wissen ja wie
ich denke es funktioniert alles was denn genau dann fällt mir das meistens nicht ein aber es
gibt sachen also sammeln wir uns zum beispiel funktionen wsl 2 irgendwo oder wsl 1 keine andere
nicht richtig port weiterleitung ja es gibt noch mehr grafische grafische anwendung ist auch so
ein ding es gibt es gibt immer wieder so dinge wurde wurde probleme hast mit wsl man fährt also
wenn man so geil mit wsl fahren würde warum sollte ich den linux vm verwenden na gut weil
ich i3 mag wie lieber als windows und ich denke schon dass man leuten die im linux umfeld unterwegs
sind in linux umgebung zur verfügung stellen muss du musst auch mal ein paar du musst auch
tools ausprobieren können du musst auch mal in den package installieren können du brauchst
auch mal was weiß ich sei es nur dass du dass du in kubectl plugin installieren willst oder
sowas was dann unter windows manchmal eventuell probleme macht weil der virenscanner meint oh
nee der lädt da was runter das will ich nicht das haben wir zum beispiel bei mir aktuell auf der
arbeit wenn ich log dateien kopiere unter wsl jetzt kein witz leute müsst euch mal reinziehen wenn
ich log dateien kopiere per scp über wsl dann bricht das nach irgendwie 25 mb ab und kriegt
ganz komische iow read write errors warum weil der virenscanner meint die log datei oder mein
scp wäre in der ransomware die gerade festplatten verschlüsselt und deswegen wird es abgebrochen
kann man über wsl den window manager laufen lassen theoretisch bestimmt praktisch ist es
unsinnig glaube nicht dass es gescheit funktioniert man kann es vielleicht laufen lassen aber ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass es gescheit funktioniert welche distribution ich auf der arbeit benutze
also ich hatte ganz lang das hier auch auf der arbeit also ok da war es noch mal jaro da war es
auch kein echtes archlinux by the way ich benutze archlinux nur dass ihr es wisst muss man muss man
glaube ich immer mal wieder ein bisschen erwähnen das erwarten die leute von einem wenn man
archlinux benutzt das ist ein bisschen somit veganer die erzählen dass die veganer sind man
muss erwähnen dass man archlinux verwendet also das war eine ganze zeit lang man jaro hatte ich
bei mir auch daheim und auf der arbeit und jetzt habe ich daheim in archlinux kein man jaro mehr
auf der arbeit habe ich tatsächlich ubuntu aber wisst ihr warum ich ubuntu habe einfacher grund
ist ich hatte dort auch meine man jaro installation und ich musste das notebook wechseln und das war
vor von nicht allzu langer zeit da wusste ich schon dass ich abhau da habe ich mir gedacht
oder ich mache jetzt keine extra arch installation auf meinem notebook und richte das schön ein
auch wenn es schnell geht mit meinen dot files aus aus aus aus dem git repo aber trotzdem ist
ein bisschen schnell aber dauert es ein bisschen länger als ubuntu als ubuntu installation aber
kommt für die für die drei monate haus sieht er noch ein ubuntu drauf und gut ist weil ich
bin auch total unmotiviert auf der arbeit muss ich ehrlich sagen es ist nicht so dass ich gar
nichts mache aber seit ich gekündigt habe bin ich extrem unmotiviert mich interessiert da auch
nichts mehr großartig ich freue mich wirklich drauf wenn es beim neuen losgeht ich habe da
überhaupt kein bock mehr drauf gerade also wie gesagt benutzt keine vm auf der arbeit ich habe
den surface book von microsoft microsoft surface book was ich rein als statisches notebook verwende
also ich verwende weder die tablet funktion noch die touch funktion auch sonst was ist es
als zugeklapptes statisches notebook mit dem monitor dran und eine usb tastatur also nichts
nichts spezielles und als linux drauf installiert und das läuft auch ganz gut auf dem surface book
official arch ja kein kein arch flavor sondern hier poggers
pogu arch
ja das ist eine gute idee
kann man für immer die free variante benutzen oder ist die sehr trash du meinst den player
der player ist ok du kannst aber auch virtual box verwenden oder oder du holst dir für 3,50
kannst du dir in meinem kiosk eine forever workstation pro lizenz holen oder vielleicht
auch aus anderen quellen aber da werde ich dir jetzt nichts schicken dazu ich habe mir die auch
aus dem key store geholt für sieben euro oder so damals und das reicht voll und ganz aus warum
mehr ausgeben als nötig sind die keys für zehn euro legit keine ahnung ist mir auch egal ich
habe die legit gekauft und sie haben legit funktioniert das ist eine mario playlist
mario sunshine
sunshine soundtrack
wie kann man nur auf die idee kommen dass man jason keine comments braucht naja weil das ursprünglich
nicht dafür gedacht war konfig dateien da drin zu erstellen oder irgendwie super menschenlesbar
zu sein wobei man halt sagen muss die erweitern wisst ihr eigentlich chat wisst ihr wisst ihr
dass jamme quasi von jason abstammt auch wenn es nicht so aussieht dass jedes gültige jason ein
gültiges jamme ist sieht ganz anders aus ist aber so auch wenn es komplett anders aussieht du kannst
jedes gültige jason in einer jammel datei speichern und es ist automatisch gültiges jamme
ja den kenne ich
den kenne ich den kenne ich ich gehe davon aus dass es nicht viele leute benutzen diesen
infinite storage glitch also ich zeige ich zeige es euch mal für leute die es nicht gesehen haben
bisher da ist jemand auf die akuma archiv archiviert ist es ok warum warum
warum ist es archiviert wahrscheinlich weil es zu viele issues gegeben hat oder der typ
hat kein bock mehr der glaube ich kein bock mehr der du kann das sein also du konntest dort dateien
umwandeln in video files die dann so aussahen quasi aus mehr oder weniger rauschen bestanden
haben und die konntest du auf youtube hochladen und youtube hat ja keine beschränkung was video
uploads angeht und dann konntest du das quasi runterladen und dann wieder zurück wandeln in
die datei das ist nichts neues dieses das verfahren an sich gibt es schon ganz lange und es ist jetzt
plus bekannt geworden so die letzten paar monate über wahrscheinlich weil hacker news oder irgendwie
oder wer auch immer das projekt entdeckt hat es gibt viele andere solcher sachen auch schon länger
ich gehe davon aus dass es kaum einer nutzt weil es nicht so du könntest damit theoretisch
sicherheitskopien über youtube verteilen natürlich nur für dich selbst ich gehe davon aus dass es
nicht so viele leute benutzen weil zu youtube sonst einfach sperren würde es ist auch nicht so
sind es ist auch nicht wirklich praktikabel gut zu benutzen die dateien also die video dateien sind
eine ganze ecke größer als die ursprungs dateien das uploaden dauert ewig wenn es größere dateien
sind du musst ja vorher noch verschlüsseln und so was kannst du auch nicht gescheit zippen na gut
du kannst du kannst du kannst zuerst zippen und dann verschlüsseln auch das funktioniert dann
den videos umwandeln die dateien sind riesengroß du brauchst lange zum upload du brauchst ja
vielleicht nicht ganz so lange zum dauerner wieder zurück also jetzt so wirklich großartig sinnvoll
finde ich es in der handhabung nicht natürlich natürlich wäre es gut für leute die irgendwelche
sachen scheren wollen größere sachen und das nicht über irgendwelche one click holster use
oder sonst was machen würden sobald das anfängt fahrt aufzunehmen wird folgendes passieren youtube
wird die dinge einfach sperren weil sowas kann youtube ja easy erkennen ob ein video so aussieht
das dürfte es dürfte youtube gar kein problem sein so und eventuell baut youtube auch wenn
es solche videos erkennt einfach einfach fehler ein sodass er nicht mehr entpackt werden können
also da glaube ich nicht dass das irgendwie großartig da jetzt irgendwie youtube aufmischen wird
3500 zeilen neowimm konf ok dann machst du das heute so wie ich das früher gemacht habe ich
früher auch komplett aufgemotzt und alles im wimm gemacht hatte ich auch ewig lang jetzt ich
weiß nicht wie lange aber ewig lange wimmrc und unterordner und alles das habe ich dann
irgendwann weggeschmissen und bin so wie studio code und jet planes rüber
motto kenne ich nicht wie gesagt ich verwende auch wenig aws das ist richtig dass für dich
als privatperson macht es überhaupt keinen sinn also sachen in der cloud zu verwenden solange
du mit free kontingent auskommst und zu kleinigkeiten braucht es gut aber jetzt irgendwie
datenbank in der cloud hause macht für dich als privatperson wenig sinn wo es für dich sinn
machen könnte ist wenn du einen service im internet anbieten willst ja also nicht von dir
für dich oder für dich daheim irgendwas sondern du hast irgendwas programmiert das willst du der
welt zur verfügung stellen dann kann das durchaus sinnvoll sein dass in der cloud laufen zu lassen
wobei man sagen muss billiger auch wenn beide auch wenn die das jetzt die ganzen verkäufer was
cloud produkte angehen wahrscheinlich anders erzählen werden weil in der cloud erzählen sie
dir immer so nach dem motto cloud ist auch riesen kostenersparnis weil du bezahlst ja nur das was
du auch wirklich verwendest naja das stimmt so ohne weiteres nicht das kommt immer ganz drauf an was
für einen serviceman verwendet und was man dort für garantien haben will was man dort für
zugriffszeiten haben will da gibt es ja ganz viele verschiedene abstufungen oftmals es ist
nicht nur ist nicht nur bei vms in der cloud wurde unterschiedliche performance ausstattung
auch bei storage zum beispiel bei storage gibt es in aws glaube drei oder fünf verschiedene
sachen du kannst das irgendwie hot nee es gibt glaube ich allein von cold storage irgendwie oder
archivspeicher irgendwie drei verschiedene stufen ist ganz wir und da bezahlst du auch
unterschiedlich viel und je nachdem ist es dann auch unterschiedlich wo du was bezahlst ja bei
dem einen ist der upload billiger und der download billiger aber dafür dafür ist das pro gigabyte
teurer und bei dem anderen ist es pro gigabyte billiger aber das abrufen ist extrem teuer
und sowas das ist riesen riesen wissenschaft für sich und du kannst in der cloud auch total easy
einfach 1000 euro ausgehen wenn du nicht aufpasst gab ja schon leute die haben es geschafft
functions serverless functions zu bauen die sich dann selbst aufgerufen haben oder um drei ecken
dann in irgendeine schleife hatten und dann sind sie ins bett und morgens sind sie aufgewacht an
70.000 euro rechnung auf ihrem account in der vergangenheit haben sich die cloud an peter da
tatsächlich relativ coolant gezeigt wahrscheinlich weil sie wussten sie bekommen das geld eh nie
und haben gesagt ja ist ok pass auf dass du nicht nicht wieder scheiße baust aber es geht
halt genauso also ich finde das macht durchaus sinn als in der cloud zu hausen aber und das ist
jetzt eigentlich das das ist eigentlich das was ich sagen wollte ja also wie gesagt ich finde da
ist nicht viel dran wenn dir irgendwelche verkäufer das sagen ja aber in der cloud ist
viel große kosten ersparen ist das billigste wenn du klein das das billigste nicht unbedingt
für dich als entwickler das einfachste aber das billigste ist höchstwahrscheinlich also wenn du
ein service hast den du im internet anbieten willst und du auch gar nicht weißt ob das viele
leute benutzen miete dir eine linux vm miete die irgendwo bei hetzer zum beispiel miete die
linux vm klatscht an eine anwendung drauf und guck erst mal wie es ankommt da kannst du zwar
nix von dem machen was die die ganzen cloud leute erzählen dass das super essentiell wäre du kannst
das nicht rolling skalieren und du kannst das nicht irgendwie großartig abcrayen ohne dass du es
runterfahren musst und solche sonstige geschichten du kannst das auch nicht per edge computing und
edge distribution und hast du nicht gesehen ausliefern aber das meiste kann man ja immer
noch später machen wenn man einfach nur was was kleines programmiert hat gucken will wie das
ankommt das billigste und einfachste ist eine linux vm bei irgendeinem holster das ding drauf
geschmissen am besten noch mit irgendeine sqlite datenbank anstatt irgendwelche der großen großen
datenbank service sich zu zu zu zu kaufen oder kannst ja auch darauf in den postklats installieren
am meisten reicht für sowas klein ist ja sogar sqlite aus wenn es komplett lokal auf dem klar auf
der gleichen kiste ist und fertig muss man gar nichts großartig machen finde ich persönlich am
sinnvollsten wenn man es einfach nur ausprobieren will und sollte man wirklich den super mega service
erfunden haben wo auf einmal die sich die leute drauf stürzen ja gut die chancen sind gering wenn
man für diese ja für diese kleine chance vorsorgen will muss man halt gelten die hand nehmen uns von
anfang an so bauen dass man es irgendwie ordentlich ausrollen könnte in der cloud umgebung des wo es
ordentlich skaliert aber er nicht zumal man vieles ja auch auf die schnelle machen kann du kannst
ja erst einmal deine vm also mehr aufrüsten also kann man kann ja erst mal die einfachen
sachen machen ja ohne dass komplett auf cloud cloud native mit allen cloud services und nur
noch im managed kubernetes cluster und hast du nicht gesehen alles laufen zu lassen also man kann
ja auch erstmal seine vms upgraden also sollte wirklich der fall eintreten dass man als
entwickler ein projekt gebaut hat das hausted der welt zur verfügung stellt auf einmal springen
tausende leute drauf und du hast auf einmal hast du hast quasi über nacht irgendwie hunderte oder
tausende user und es geht es geht ab weil zufälligerweise pewdiepie ein video über
deinen service gemacht hat ja gut da kannst du erst mal einfach deine vm erweitern gibt
seiner vm erraten gibt seine vm cpu und das ist dann erst einmal kommste damit ja auch relativ
weit und dann musst du dir halt überlegen ok ich habe auf einen schlag 500 benutzer jetzt
muss ich mir tatsächlich ein bisschen mühe geben mit dem service wobei nur halt meistens ja noch
nicht mal irgendwie ein abo modell oder irgendwas hast wenn du einfach als privatperson was gebaut
hast gucken willst wie es ankommt da hast ja noch nicht mal in die monetarisierungs schema die
ausgedacht das ist ja meistens dann kostenloser web service und da kann sich dann eh keiner
beschweren also du hast wie sehe ich prinzipiell auch so ich finde das meistens ist es für private
personen so für so ein mann projekte nicht sonderlich sinnvoll kommt drauf an was man
macht ja also ich habe gehört dass wir mittlerweile sechs stellig im monat ausgeben für die cloud bei
ihm bei meinem aktuellen arbeitgeber also es ist nicht nicht ohne was da er geld raus reingebuttert
wird aber wenn du das brauchst was die anbieten dann kann sich das durchaus lohnen es hat ja sein
grund dass die cloud anbieter erfolgreich sind und das auch immer mal wieder neue auftauchen
die manche sachen besonders gut machen oder einfacher machen oder fokussierter sind auf
spezielle bereiche als die großen ich meine klar google microsoft und amazon die können irgendwie
alles dafür sind sie unglaublich komplex groß kompliziert und keiner blickt so wirklich durch
am anfang und ich glaube es gibt ganz wenige die wirklich insgesamt durchblicken dann gibt
es dann irgendwelche service was die flyer was jetzt gerade voll angesagt ist was spezielle
sachen einfacher macht und dementsprechend auch für viele erstmal einfacher zu verstehen ist
die note habe ich noch nie verwendet habe ich auch aber ich habe schon öfters mal als guten
tipp gehört für managet kuppernetz und so managet in anführungen strichen viel managet ist ja da
nicht bei und digital außen kuppernetz soll auch nicht schlecht sein ansonsten wie die vms von
den not sind habe ich auch nicht schlechtes bisher gehört managet ist bei diesen ganzen sachen ja
nicht wirklich viel sondern eigentlich nur die wie heißt das kuppernetz die api das eigentliche
kuppernetz die control plane heißt das genau also ist ja meistens der kuppernetz service selber
managt also du kannst dann zum beispiel da drüber ab dass die gucken dann halt dass das versions
upgrades durchgeführt werden in irgendeinem maintain in zwinder was du ein was du eingetragen
hast dass du dich nicht selbst machen mussten solche geschichten aber um alles andere in
deinem cluster auch wenn es ein managet cluster ist musste dich bei den meisten anbietern dort
selber kümmern da haben die größeren anbieter was was cooleres google hat zum beispiel so was wie
ihren kuppernetz autopilot da kriegst du gar kein kuppernetz cluster mehr im klassischen sinne
sondern du kriegst ein kuppernetz cluster wo du per pot bezahlt oder nicht per pot per doch
per ich bin mir nicht sicher ob du es per pot bezahlt oder ob du es per pot typ bezahlt aber
wahrscheinlich wirst du es nach pot bezahlen und dann halt je nachdem wie viele replikas und sonst
was man haben will dafür musste dich halt null mehr drum kümmern um kuppernetz an sich ist
dann noch mal so ein zwischenschritt zwischen alles serverless funktions oder kombiniertes cluster
so ein zwischending
was das für betge musik
das habe ich gesehen das habe ich gesehen ich glaube nicht dass das das ziehen wird wenn ich
das sage
obwohl unity gibt es doch gar nicht mehr oder das ist doch jetzt alles auch genommen
welchen key store benutzt du so für corporate meinst du key store oder oder secret store also
meinst du key value geschichten oder wirklich in secret store secret store azure key vault ganz
einfach weil azure und so zeug weil wir azure verwenden und da bietet sich das an
azure key vault und ansonsten redis es dürfte auch mittags verbreitet sein was was so so cashing
und solche geschichten angeht
jammel kompiliert ja unter der haube zu jason oder nicht das weiß ich nicht es gibt allerdings
sachen konstrukte in jammel die kannst du in jason so nicht machen zum beispiel referenzen
und so was aber klar wenn das irgendwie dann zu jason kompiliert dann glaube ich nicht
passt eigentlich nicht
jason jammel ist keine alternativ sonntags für jason also nicht jedes jammel ist jason aber jedes
jason ist jammel
ich benutze das main ubuntu ja das ganz das das ganz stink normale ubuntu benutze ich was du
kriegst wenn du wenn du sagst hier download ubuntu verschicken die eigentlich noch kostenlos cds
früher haben noch cds verschickt das was du hier kriegst hier 22 04 lts
wir sind übrigens sehe ich gerade wir sind bald bei ubuntu 22 23 04 wie wird denn das heißen
luna lobster endlich mal wieder ein guter ubuntu name die letzten waren irgendwie nicht so geil
die letzten fand ich nicht so geil aber luna lobster ist poggers ja so das war cool das war
cool war sich es war zu zweien denkt er den kann ich mich auch noch erinnern den das ist
glaube ich den namen der mir den ich am meisten noch im kopf habe was ubuntu angeht ja die kenne
ich alle noch aber die war jetzt auch nicht so geil haben die nicht einfach mal eine tabelle
wo man das sieht so eklig so wie soll man das aber die letzten die letzten muss ich sagen die
fand ich jetzt gar nicht mehr so gar nicht mehr so toll die kineci kudu das zungenbrecher das
spricht doch keiner so aus luna lobster ist mal wieder was was gut von der zunge geht das
gemi jellyfish ok das wusste ich gar nicht dass es existiert wenn ich ehrlich bin ist mir komplett
neu habe ich bis jetzt noch nicht gesehen wusste ich gar nicht dass ubuntu 21.10 so hieß habe ich
gelesen war fand ich auch doof fand ich auch doof ja das kenne ich noch aber ganz ehrlich das luna
lobster ist mal wieder was gutes dass sie gleich wie bei debian nee debianer toy story namen
debian benutzt ihr benennt ihre dinge immer nach toy story characters ubuntu macht da irgendwelche
komischen wie nennt man das diese konstellation von wörtern bei ubuntu wie nennt man das also
luna lobster ist ja quasi dass es nennt hier ist mit l nennt wort mit l am anfang
was halt irgendwie eine eigenschaft dann von dem tier
adjektiv und hier ja genau aber es muss aber es muss immer das gleiche adjektiv sein vom
anfangs gleiche anfangs buchstaben adjektiv wie im tier name bei ubuntu
was ihr wechselt auch wieder zurück von der cloud
aha
das leuchten verstehe ich jetzt den zusammenhang irgendwie nicht
was hat was hat der rails erfinder und google damit zu tun dass er gut keine ahnung
präzilsnacker danke für den sub sorry leute was ich heute wieder die hälfte überlesen
ab wahrscheinlich war der macht schicko so schicko kratzt an der türen
ja und er hat es archiviert aber warum weiß man nicht oder weiß man das
wie ist der typ github infinite storage klitsch also immer in der source code ist noch da
rework update readme ok was hat er was hat er da reingeschrieben warum hat er das gelöscht
oh ich glaube youtube hat ihn angeschrieben könnte das sein
o
so
ja das ist weiß nicht ob das die leute erzählen im internet viel wenn der tach lang ist
kostlose ubuntu cds gibt es schon lange nicht mehr
es gibt ein ubuntu remix mit dem alten unity aber warum das denn das fand ich ja noch schlimmer
als den gnome desktop von denen. Leute falls ihr irgendwelche fragen übersehen habt schreibt
es ruhig in den chat rein ich habe wieder die hälfte jetzt gerade überscrollt wahrscheinlich
Ed Wubblos davor ja ich bin unten im chat ich habe noch im hinterkopf gehabt irgendwas wollte
ich noch beantworten aber weiß nicht mehr was
keine ahnung ach stimmt unity wird ja von diesem 13 jährigen typ weiterentwickelt ja ja haben wir
sogar letztens gesehen der hatte doch noch mehr oder der hat nicht nur an unity entwickelt der
hatte noch auch irgendwelche anderen projekte wo wir uns gedacht haben es ist ein zwölfjähriger
oder so der das programmiert ich habe gar kein laufwerk mehr im brechner drinnen meine letzten
paar rechner hatten alle schon kein laufwerk mehr es haben ein paar leute gefragt wann ich
jetzt letzten arbeitstag und ersten arbeitstag habe also dazu gibt es ein update ich habe euch
ja mal erzählt mein letzter arbeitstag ist spätestens der 22. und je nach hofbereitschafts
konto vielleicht schon der 17. und mein erster arbeitstag ist der erste beziehungsweise der ja
dritte oder vierte je nachdem ob ich monat wahrscheinlich gehe ich gleich anfangen der
woche hin der dritte dritte april ist mein erster mein erster arbeitstag aber es hat sich
jetzt was anderes ergeben ich habe nämlich folgendes entdeckt und zwar wenn man innerhalb
eines jahres den arbeitgeber wechselt kann man seine urlaubstage mitnehmen wenn wenn man
eine bescheinigung bekommt vom also wenn der alte und der neue arbeitgeber damit einverstanden sind
und wenn man eine bescheinigung bekommt vom alten arbeitgeber wie viele urlaubstage man schon
verbraucht hat dieses jahr so dass man halt nicht sagen kann hey ich nehme die mit aber ich will
sie auch ausbezahlt haben eine woche später oder sowas das wäre dann wäre beschiss so mein neuer
arbeitgeber erlaubt das anscheinend weil die haben sogar eine möglichkeit ein das formular
das hochzuladen jetzt muss ich mal bei meinem aktuellen arbeitgeber fragen ob das ok ist
ich denke nicht dass die was dagegen haben die freuen sich wahrscheinlich sogar wenn
ich noch eine woche länger da bin bezahlen müssen sie es ja eh und dann wäre mein letzter arbeitstag
tatsächlich erst wahrscheinlich der 29 was mir persönlich auch ganz lieb ist weil ich habe
überhaupt kein interesse den und den sechs tageurlaub jetzt zu nehmen null ich will ich will
überhaupt kein urlaub nehmen ich will lieber wieder urlaub ordentlich am stück nehmen und
nicht irgendwie so sechs tage so im märz ist total bescheuert habe ich will ich überhaupt nicht
deswegen werde ich das mal checken ob das geht ich will jetzt überhaupt keinen urlaub machen
ist fulltime office home office bei dem neuen nee es ist nicht fulltime home office es ist einmal
die woche bis zu 14 tage also einmal die woche oder einmal die alle 14 tage office je nach absprache
mit seinem chef ich denke mal am anfang werde ich da schon einmal die woche hingehen allein
schon dass man ein bisschen so die leute mal gesehen hat und dann mal gucken ob man das
ein bisschen ausweitet da wird sich nichts mehr großartig tun die übergabe ist abgeschlossen
gibt eigentlich nichts was ich übergeben muss nur ich muss mich vielleicht selbst übergeben wenn
ich sehe wie bescheuert sie das wieder gemacht haben die haben einen kerl dahin gesetzt der die
sachen von mir alle übernehmen soll der die sachen von meinem kollege übernehmen soll der mit auch
mit mir wechselt teilweise zumindest dann macht er noch die sachen weiter die er vorher gemacht hat
plus dass er sich jetzt noch mit unserem mail system auseinandersetzen soll wie soll das
funktionieren das und das beste ist das beste ist das ist ein externer mitarbeiter der nur
ein vertrag für ein halbes jahr hat da ist dann weg und auf einmal haben die gar keinen plan mehr
was abgeht also die schau da schaufen sie sich gerade wirklich ihr grab der haut einfach ab wenn
auch vollkommen vollkommen zurecht
also keine ahnung was es sich dabei wieder gedacht haben ja morgen habe ich noch mal ein
termin mit meinem chef da werde ich das machen werde ich das klären wie das mit dem mit dem
urlaub mit dem urlaub nehmen ist und und was mein abschlusszeugnis macht abschlusszeugnis müssen
sie nämlich auch endlich mal hinkriegen ich habe das ich habe das alles ausgefüllt mein
chef hat es auch ausgefüllt und irgendwie hört man dann nichts mehr von die sind total lahm was
das angeht und ich brauche das abschlusszeugnis also was heißt brauchen nicht wirklich aber ich
will eins haben wie wo ist das wo ist das problem viele e-mails zu benutzen das kann
ich überhaupt nicht verstehen ist nicht ist nicht immer eigentlich das beste an ganz twitch
beste einfach nur den ganzen tag emotes spam ich habe auch keine probleme wenn
der chat remote only ist wobei das mag ich nicht eigentlich mag ich mag ich
nicht nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein wieder ausmachen ja es machen aber
emotes sind doch echt das beste eigentlich so das mal kurz kommen wir klotzen doch immer
irgendwas auf wir gucken uns noch mal irgendwas auf auf youtube an gibt es da irgendwelche
spanne the brutal downfall auf benna twitch tv one extension that millions of ok lass mal
so auf was haben wir denn zu was haben wir denn zur auswahl zu gucken ffm pack in 100 sekunden ok
war feier schipp kommen wir gucken feier schipp ffm pack ist tatsächlich beste also ich glaube
ich könnte ich könnte keine videos ohne ffm pack mehr erstellen in open source command line ffm
pack in open source command line tool for processing audio and video files it was created by
fabrice billard in the year 2000 the name stands for fast forward followed by the moving picture
experts group file format today it's used in a wide variety of tools dafür steht das ok ich
wusste bis jetzt nicht ffm pack steht was like google chrome and blender und das logo ist auch kacke
well it's video platforms like youtube and vimeo it's able to decode encode transcode multiplex
demultiplex stream filter and play virtually any multimedia file in the world with over 100
different codecs support it it works by taking an input file then passes it to a demultiplexer
that splits the audio and video tracks into separate encoded data packets these packets
are then decoded into uncompressed frames which can be further processed and filtered you might
modify the brightness and contrast add subtitles or visualize the audio essay that does the best
das beste an ffm pack ist ja dass das um encoden von einem format ins andere format das ist das
wo es wahrscheinlich auch mit abstand die meisten leute benutzen halt im endeffekt zum video rendern
war damals gerade die windows build suite oder verwende ich ja wahrscheinlich sachen von einem
arbeitskollege war dann feinlich die sprains art hat natürlich auch ffm pack installiert
multiplex back into the output file in addition it also comes with the ff play tool to easily play
media from the command line and ff probe to extract metadata from a file in addition to
tons of low-level libraries for developers building their own multimedia processing ffm pack kann
fast alles einzige was ffm pack nicht kann was mich ein bisschen stört ist wie heißt dieses
komische nachfolge format was ich google ausgedacht hat für png web web nein nein nein web p ja genau
das kann ffm pack nicht und ich verstehe nicht warum oder animiertes web p kann es nicht animiertes
wer p kann es nicht irgendwie so gab es da gab es da probleme ich merke dass ich merke das immer
wieder weil ich zum beispiel suche nach betta twitch tv keck weh oder oder oder keine ahnung
wenn ich irgendwelche animierten die mode suche sind die manchmal in webp animation formaten das
kriegt ffm pack nicht hin benutzt du dein self made pop shots noch ja den habe ich immer noch
dran hier guck das ist immer noch mein schwamm den ich am mikrofon stecken habe
nee das funktioniert nicht guck mal ffz nehmen wir mal gachi roll oder sowas hier so wenn ich
das runter lade ist das webp also keckel so achtung achtung downloads ff play
im instater not found
es geht nicht könnte das sein dass einfach diese dass es nicht alles kann von webp
also der browser kann es aber ffm pack kann es nicht im instater not found das habe ich
jetzt schon ein paar mal gemerkt dass ffm pack mit dem format probleme hat
ach guck mal das kann die encode aber nicht die kauten
moment die können bilder erstellen aber bilder nicht einlesen
gut wie gesagt das weiß ich dass das ist damit probleme hat ansonsten ist ffm pack des beste
was ffm pack minus image 2 ok geht das geht das auch bei ff play
nee ok ff ffm pack probieren das jetzt mal aus minus die was image 2 warum image 2 ok
image 2 aber aber das den moment minus e geht auch gar nicht minus e ist das input file chat
was ihr wieder was zeug schreibt es gibt überhaupt keinen sinn
minus f image 2 ok ok ff play minus f image 2 ok geht das bei ff play vielleicht
image no data found oder oder muss man das f nach minus i machen
nee nee keine chance
sie vor sieben jahren ok
nee das jpg kann ffm pack ja auch weil es den encoder hat und es hat keinen decoder hierfür
gibt's nicht deswegen geht das auch nicht
benutzt kaum einer hier kannst du übrigens auch sachen skippen und so was du kannst ja
auch mit ffm pack videos schneiden auf der kommando zeile wenn man will und es gibt minus s ist skip
am keyframe und minus ss ist skip exakt zum timestamp oder so bin mir im kopf nicht ganz
sicher gibt zwei gibt zwei gibt minus ss und minus s als kommentar als als nicht als kommentar als
option use with t to trim a certain number of seconds off of the video footage but the most
powerful option might be vf which creates a filter graph that can handle transformations like rotation
ich skaliere damit übrigens seit einer weile meine videos hoch weil ich nehme ja selbst
1080p auf aber die bandbreite in 1080p auf youtube ist einfach müll deswegen skaliere
ich die einfach hoch auf 1440p und dann sieht sie sehen sie auf einmal viel besser aus
ich will ja ffm pack verwenden leute dass es irgendein anderes tool gibt was das kann
gehe ich jetzt mal von aus ich mein image magic habe ich überhaupt image magic installiert kann
das kann das wahrscheinlich auch ja image
das image to web p was zum was ist das
convert ne wie heißt das programm zum anzeigen bei image magic keine ahnung egal ich installiere
image magic ist
legacy zeug west from ne das glaube ich nicht gucken wir mal gucken wir mal
ich würde sagen kann es nicht hat aber ich mein es geht auf jeden fall in die richtige
aber hat von bisschen noch probleme damit also kann es kann es auch nicht richtig wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich kann es statische images und nicht animierte images
ne ne ne keine chance das kann es nicht mich jetzt auch gewundert
ja lass mal kurz youtube reload ob da noch irgendwas spannendes dabei dabei ist was
building a rack mounted proxmox server ja soll er machen müssen wir uns jetzt aber nicht angucken
das ist sehr unspektakulär
haben wir noch irgendwas wir haben noch eine halbe stunde zeit kommt irgendwas irgendwas
spannendes gibt es doch noch linux fundamental mentals fundamental cement ach du scheiße was
fundamental ist oder metaverse ist dead ok ist das wirklich so
mark zuckerberg ist es so ich mein der übertreibt das hat übertreibts auch
manchmal ganz schön mit seinem zeug was er da erzählt ja man kann es davon abgesehen dass
das irgendjemand irgendwann irgendwann wieder irgendwann abhebt wie sie sich das erhofft haben
habe ich eh schwarz gesehen aber nur weil ich das so weil ich das nicht sehe das plan
hey guck mal die leute haben jetzt auf einmal füße ich dachte im metaverse hat keiner mehr
beine und füße und wie kommt er da jetzt drauf ok wir gucken mal kurz kurz news
es stimmt überhaupt nicht ok gibt keine weitere news dazu alles klar gut nice gg
alles klar ja der übertreibt manchmal so ein bisschen so also gucken wir uns mal das an
the brutal downfall of betta twitch tv verwendet noch jemand betta twitch tv von euch leute ich
verwende nur noch ffz und nachdem ffz auch betta twitch tv emotes kann und 7 tv emotes
kann macht es eigentlich gar keinen sinn für mich mehr
idee für altes notebook als server so was wie proxmox drauf oder was anderes das kommt
drauf an das leute es macht keinen sinn irgendeine alte kiste hinzustellen und daraus ein
virtualisierungshaus zu machen wenn man nichts hat was man virtualisieren will
oder hast du was was zu virtualisieren willst weil dann hast du es hier quasi schon selbst
beantwortet dass es sinn macht wenn dir die leistung ausreicht und wenn deine cpu das kann
ansonsten sind alte notebooks da ganz gut für ich meine die sind meistens recht leise die
brauchen nicht viel strom und die haben je nach notebook auch ganz ok leistung kann man verwenden
für sowas
habt ihr eine idee wie ich einen terminal ui dialog der sehr wahrscheinlich mit dialog
erstellt wurde in einem script dialog ist das diese ist das das ding mit diesem blauen
hintergrund und den den grafischen dingern zum auswählen dann die ich habe vergessen wie das
heißt dieses wie nennt sich das denn das hat so einen speziellen namen diese art von dir von
ja ich zeig's euch mal was gekacke wie benutzt man das meine ich genau ach du kacke wie macht
man das wie benutzt man das überhaupt wie benutzt man thomas dick hat das programmiert
so so wie macht man das ich habe keine ahnung wie man das überhaupt benutzt kalender was form
gibt sich einfach textbox ok textbox textbox naja da gibt es nicht lull
sollte ich bin unfähig das zu benutzen
ok wie geht das zeig mal ein beispiel dialog off hier beispiel please ja ja ja ja ja ja und wie
geht's yes no möchten sie abrecht ok alles klar das will ich haben genau so das willst du
automatisieren
das doch einfach
du willst x do x x do tool haben da kannst du an fenster tasten input senden und du willst
an den tasten input senden einmal feiltaste rechts und enter kannst du machen
die presses das weiß ich aber aus dem kopf gerade nicht wie das funktioniert ja gucken
wir mal gucken wir mal wie das funktioniert hier press key n genau ok also machst du hier press
key n und enter ok macht den dialog auf i n und jetzt müssen wir das noch ans richtige ans
richtige also das fenster fenster muss ja so sein groß n ja wir müssen sie wir müssen
es irgendwie im gleichen wir müssen es irgendwie im gleichen fenster ausführen das wird das wird
es ein bisschen eklig von der sonntags her so können wir das können wir das so machen
ok das hat nicht funktioniert also es wird aber funktionieren wenn man es im zweiten wenn man
im zweiten fenster macht und jetzt musste halt hier angeben an welches fenster du das senden
willst das weiß ich aber aus dem kopf ehrlich gesagt nicht wie das wie das funktioniert das
musste nachgucken to specific window
ja klar es blabla da kannst du einstellen an welches fenster du deine tasten drücke
tasten drücke schicken willst es gibt theoretisch die möglichkeit das ganze auch noch in ex expect
oder so zu rappen aber das funktioniert glaube ich für grafische tools nicht bzw. auch für
für grafische kommandos also konsolen tools nicht da wirst du wahrscheinlich tasten input
senden müssen ja sag ich das kenne ich schon das habe ich letztens das habe ich letztens auch
schon gezeigt ja das ist eklig zu automatisieren aber da wird allerdings alles übrig bleiben wie
sowas zu machen hier sende sende key hier sende key yes hat doch funktioniert hat auch hat
auch funktioniert hier sleep 2 kok geht doch
er alright wie macht man das
key up down right ok also kann man auch kann man auch sagen quasi right und enter oder so
er hat auch funktioniert guck er ist nach rechts er ist nach rechts
geswitcht und macht enter kannst du kannst du komm geht ja sag beim switch rechts enter
haben wir einen sleep einbauen zwischen zwischen den einzelnen dingern
ja guck jetzt macht er sogar so so so funktioniert das nicht
ok also das funktioniert so nicht wie ich mir das gedacht habe mit dem sleep aber das kannst du so
kannst du so automatisieren ja die mikron vergessen nee ich wollte es hier dazwischen
einmal und ich dachte das geht vielleicht dass man das direkt da in line in line einbauen kann
weil weil ansonsten müsste ich jetzt ja so machen sleep eins und dann noch mal und dann
enter und so das natürlich auch doof als switch darüber macht ein sleep und drückt enter ich
würde auch jede menge sleeps einbauen an deiner stelle weil ansonsten ist es vielleicht nicht
schnell genug ja wenn das geht wenn das geht ist natürlich sinniger aber wenn
du wirklich was automatisieren willst willst in der kommando zeile mit tasten drücken dann
bleibt er nur so was ist eine stelle als junior kubernetes admin ja fragt die mal wie sie kubernetes
aussprechen ist es kubernetes ist es kubernetes oder sowas und wenn die sagen kubernetes dann
sagst du gleich nicht zu euch will ich nicht keine ahnung was ich dir als junior admin im
vorstellungsgespräch raten soll außer das was man immer raten kann nicht so wirklich jetzt aber
spezifisch zu kubernetes ja das würde ich nicht mal das sind aber so allgemeine themen ich
überlege gerade was man explizit für die stelle als junior kubernetes admin sagen könnte kommt
halt darauf an bei wem du das vorstellungsgespräch hast hast du das bei irgendeinem der ahnung hat
oder ist es nur so ein erstes scangespräch von irgendeinem typ von der recruiting firma oder von
irgendeinem personaler der eh keinen plan davon hat also ist da jemand ist da vielleicht vielleicht
weißt du das das also das also dort wo ich jetzt vorstellungsgespräche hatte stand immer dabei wer
teilnimmt am vorstellungsgespräch ich hatte aber in letzter zeit nur zwei und eins war direkt mit
dem mit dem mit dem chef also oder mit dem mit dem ist ja nicht chef es ist ja der was ist der
technikchef der mit dem cto wobei das halt auch eine kleinere kleinere firma war also da wusste
ich halt mit wem ich rede und bei den anderen stand immer dabei ist neben teil bla bla bla team
leiter bereiche blablabla personalabteilung ein paar aus dem team alle was wollte ich da irgendwie
die mal so ich finde es immer schon ein bisschen cringe wenn da einem drei leute gegenüber
ja also mir fällt jetzt ehrlich gesagt so kubernetes admin spezifisches jetzt nix so
direkt ein was man da vielleicht mit was man punkten kann ich mein du willst ja schon ein
bisschen erfahrung haben als kubernetes mit kubernetes ich meine es ist zwar eine junior
als kubernetes admin da wird wahrscheinlich anforderungen sein dass man zumindest ein
bisschen plan von kubernetes hat meinung zu feve ich habe schon ewig jahre nichts mehr
von feve gelesen keine ahnung was der aktuell treibt ja natürlich kannst ein bisschen von
deinen erfahrungen berichten was du schon gemacht hast und ansonsten nur das allgemeine zeug fällt
jetzt gerade so spontan nichts ein du versuchst checkmk updates zu automatisieren und bei omd
das ist der das kommando zeilen tool von checkmk oder dover dialog ja sagt
bester tipp leute kein scheiß machen ich glaube diesen tipp kannst du auf 99 prozent der
lebenssituation anwenden just just kein scheiß machen das geht immer und wenn es nicht läuft
dann wahrscheinlich zu viel scheiß gemacht
oh leute ich habe gerade eine nachricht von twitch bekommen das werbeprogramm von twitch
wird noch flexibler im april ist mir egal ich habe glaube ich noch nicht einmal werbung laufen
lassen in meinem stream hier also werbung wo man auf diesen werbe button drückt wenn wenn
überhaupt kommen werbung wenn ihr einschaltet weil ich da nichts dagegen machen kann aber ich
habe nicht einmal werbeknopf gedrückt ich habe natürlich schon werbung gezeigt weil ich
sponsoring sachen in streams hatte aber ich habe nie werbe getrübt werbung werbeunterbrechung
gedrückt bisher das werbeprogramm ist auch ist auch sehr unsinnig hast du eigentlich eine ausbildung
ich habe systemintegration gelernt 2007 ist ja bis hierher geht richtig aussprechen das
war nicht verkehrt geht richtig auszusprechen was man sollte sich aussprechen
nö
kenne ich nicht ist das ist das ist das das von den battlefield leuten von den ex-battlefield leuten
ja ist es ist es ist es bekommt bisher gute kritiken okay ist das rausgekommen schon
an den ehemaligen dais entwickler close beta zu den pc gestalte ok ok
alles klar wäre doch cool wenn die was auf die reihe kriegen man da ist hat es ja nicht auf
die reihe gekriegt die letzten jahre aber auch gut wenn jetzt was neues wenn jetzt was neues
schaffen ich habe übrigens irgendwas heute gelesen das habe ich nicht ganz gecheckt vielleicht
flicken da irgendwelche tiktok enjoyer von euch durch ich habe gelesen es gibt einen neuen
tiktok trend dass man bei irgendeinem kinofilm nur bei einem bestimmten kinofilm mit cola mit
cola flaschen gegen die leinwand werfen soll so lange bis der film abgebrochen wird was zum
teufel ist da auf tiktok wieder los kreid möglich ja du hast recht kreid drei warum
und warum warum also pick das irgendjemand hat irgendjemand eine ahnung warum weil die dummen
sind ok das ist natürlich die ultimative erklärung für alle tiktok geschichten aber
wo kommt was ist da wieder los man ist es immer noch ein besserer trend es ist immerhin noch
ein besserer trend als wäschetapps essen das war wirklich so die krönung und wisst ihr wisst ihr
was gleichzeitig der dümmste und tragischste trend überhaupt war von dem ich von von dem ich von
dem ich so direkt gar nichts mitbekommen habe aber man hat die opfer die opfer gesehen also
das war es gab auf tiktok eine ich erhänge mich challenge es war nicht wirklich eine ich erhänge
mich challenge wo es sich mal vorstellt alle tiktok die sind wirklich komplett komplett ab
es gab es gab eine challenge da ging es darum sich selber sich selber bewusstlos zu wirken
und wenn man das schon ausspricht stellt man fest wie unglaublich bescheuert das alles ist
so und ich habe das nur mitgekriegt weil es vor einer weile eine größere diskussion um
lebenserhaltende maßnahmen war das glaube ich gab in england und da gab es ein kind das lag
jetzt irgendwie keine ahnung zwei jahre oder so mit mit hirntod im krankenhaus und da habe ich
mal die geschichte zu durchgelesen das hat sich selbst quasi für eine tiktok challenge so erhängt
und die mutter hat es halt gefunden wo es zu spät war kam das kind ins krankenhaus hirn halt schon
komplett hinüber und da ging es dann letztendlich darum ob die geräte abgestellt werden dürfen und
es war eine riesen geschichte in uk und da geht es gar nicht so sehr darum es ging mir jetzt um die
tiktok challenge also es gab wohl wirklich eine tiktok challenge wo die leute sich selbst gewürgen
sollten bis zum bewusstlos werden und da muss man sich sagen man kann sich doch schon überlegen
egal wie jung und wie blöd man ist dass die sauerstoffzufuhr zum gehirn abschneiden nicht
sonderlich gut sein kann also ich meine es ist doch gar nicht möglich dass man nicht
dass man das nicht merkt dass es eine doofe idee ist das muss einem doch klar sein
als tiktok zeug ich blick dann immer durch
ja gut das ist ja wieder was anderes sich mit kleber an der straße festkleben
was was künstlich hyperventilieren nee nee nee es gab die aufs herz drücken musst du nicht
es gab ein trend wo die leute hyperventiliert haben im liegen und dann schnell aufgestanden
sind so dass sie bewusstlos werden das haben sie gefilmt das ist so klar es ist so unglaublich
dämlich das ist so bescheuert man aber die welche tabs challenge war schon auch absolute
absolute krönung von tiktok trends bisher ja meine ich ja
zu sechs dem vorstellungsgespräch dann mal gucken hoffentlich hoffentlich schwätzen
sie dich nicht so nicht so voll von allen seiten gleichzeitig haben ein bisschen struktur
drinne also machst du schon ich mein du hast ja hoffentlich ahnung von dem thema das kannst
du den ja auch ruhig verkaufen dass du ahnung von dem thema hast ansonsten ja achso wir wollten
ein video gucken fällt mir gerade ein kann man anwendungen die auf einem container eigentlich
ja kann man also sprich nix dagegen das zu machen also rein von der machbarkeit
her geht das klar warum sollte es nicht gehen
was machst du aktuell bist du projektleiter god des willen bloß nicht wenn du wissen willst
was ich beim aktuellen arbeitgeber mache guck einfach mal ich habe auf youtube ja so was
habe ich gemacht warum das mein ich habe relativ viele videos zu dem thema schon gemacht kannst
ich auf youtube mal umgucken da ist das auch alles ein bisschen ausführlicher was ich erzählt habe
aber ich bin glücklicherweise kein projektleiter und ich habe auch keine ambitionen projektleiter
zu werden wir müssen jetzt aber das video noch gucken weil sind ja nur sieben minuten
wir fangen noch von vorne an guckt euch mal an richtig ein richtig nicer kakona stecker
custom emotes animator emotes and various in-depth settings that weren't present on twitch at the time
being able to be downloaded to every major browser better ttb zu projektleiter amuen das
ist jetzt das ist jetzt ein clip ich dachte es irgendwas von früher was the twitch extension
everyone used and loved for years the developers who created nightbot put together better ttv
und ja neid pot neid pot hat bei mir auch ein paar aussetzer öfters mal it was something quite
unique well i believe franker face z was released around the same time to this day ffz is still
like the middle child in terms of emote extensions better ttv or bt tv reigns supreme with no sort
of competition and i mean why would they have any it's a twitch emote extension you use it to get
the silly little frog in your chat and that's really its sole purpose surely there wouldn't be any drama
to a chrome extension january 6 2021 would be a huge day for the twitch is your inner image is your inner image
for all the wrong reasons the face of the pogchamp emote gutex is your inner image opinion on the right at the us
capital i know this just went zero to 101 sentence but this was the reason why he was removed as the
face of the emote on twitch is where i believe the very very beginning of the end for better ttv
started as a reaction to twitch removing the emote franker face z removed every pogchamp emote variant
basically any imagery with gutex's face in it was off their extension besides pog that one stayed
with better ttv saying that they will not be removing any pog emotes in general better ttv
has never removed emotes due to controversies and likely won't as a result of this behavior
in retrospect this was the right choice for better ttv because during this time all the
big streamers wanted to seem like they were doing a big service to the streaming community
by changing their pogchamp emotes to something different only for them to all flip back to
using gutex emotes like four months later but that statement they released would also backfire on
them because in february of 2021 better ttv decided to remove the emote zulo off their website
now this one i definitely agree should have been removed i mean look at it man after its removal
it was promptly replaced with a new zulo but because of that something in the dark depths was
cooking something was brewing in the spring of 2021 a new extension would be making the rounds
around smaller streamers chats seven tv in reaction to the emotes better ttv was removing
this extension was created now the big deal about
this unknown seven tv at the time was its impressive 200 base emote slots at launch it seemed like
such a no-brainer to swap really thinking about it now i seriously cannot believe better ttv was
able to swindle people out of five bucks a month for absolutely nothing in return like one to two
slots you would get and then it would max out i robbed you bro i'm gonna keep it i'm gonna keep it
brought to the table like zero width emotes allowing you to stack emotes on top of each other
and name paints for further customizability okay that's actually quite a lot of people to
download the extension the problem with the extension at launch was truly it didn't take
itself too seriously causing some questionable emotes to be plastered all over the website
or hidden private emotes only visible if you visited the user's profile there was so much
potential for this extension to take off and be better than any extension available and after
some criticism they took it to heart because they got to work almost immediately fixing the
emote issues and moderation problems slowly but surely the number of users on the website began
to grow and it grew enough to where it was time to start getting emote integration on the other
extensions emote integration allows users to install only one of the main emote extensions
but will still be able to see all three of the extensions that's where things get funky
they easily got the integration now for better ttv in various chats seven tv users were asking
better tv devs about emote integration this could be chalked up to just general shit talk
and it wasn't directly from the creator night but a few staff members were pretending they didn't
know what seven tv was which doesn't make sense considering they are better tv staff members
like you would think you would know or catch wind of the new extension that everyone is talking
about on october 9 2022 this little twitter thread would be the start of a little tiny beef between
the creator of better tv night and the creator of seven tv anatole what is skipped
and soft beefs zwischen chrome add-on creator and emotes are finally here you can now upload
emails with up to three times more width from your dashboard dead app seven tv on top yeah but
seven tv is taking away too much information about you and your viewers so i would not recommend to
you seven tv is taking way too much information about you okay also sprich er sagt das quasi so
tracking eingebaut tv from what i've heard they have bots which sit in all the twitch chat collecting
data and when the bots get banned it rejoins on a different account ie you can't get rid of it dude
your extension has an option to see the chat while banned a bot rejoining on anon is no different
speak about unethical while your service literally demands hundreds of dollars for
that same month under what i believe was now a deleted promotional tweet from twitch
night would be seen under that tweet throwing more shade at seven tv this sure looks like
ban evasion to me which is definitely against the at twitch community guidelines it's surprising
twitch streamers slash viewers continue to promote seven tv given their unethical practices this
response is not what you'd expect from a company acting with good intent now all this shit talk
only ever started once seven tv began to become a real threat financially to better tv that's
when night started this little campaign to shit talk and i'm sure he thought it would go amazing
i mean he created better tv he must have all the twitch ogs by his side he ended up nuking his
whole twitter page and has been extremely silent since this encounter up until january 18th of
2023 a huge massive gargantuan update for better tv dropped i am not exaggerating when i tell you
one to one bar for bar they stole every single feature that made seven tv unique loyalty badges
larger emote slots emote renaming and they changed their logo to a scuffed ass face punch studios
wer hat denn jetzt von was geklaut
better twitch tv hat von seven tv oder wie geklaut
the most interesting addition though was what's this seven tv support has it finally happened
have all the emote extensions made peace and we can finally live happily ever after well when
ticking the seven tv box you were met with a very backhanded message disguised as a very
heartfelt warning from what i can't help but assume was written by night himself
over one million users in almost two years and every big streamer having the extension enabled
in their chat i believe it is safe to say there is a new king of twitch emote extensions
aktivieren oder so also einmal verknüpfen mit twitch
ja easy ja solange ihre moderationsprobleme in griff gekriegt haben mache ich das
with consistent updates and an owner who doesn't attempt to burn bridges instead in the past was
hopeful for a world where all extensions could work together but clearly with that not being
possible seven tv has cemented itself in twitch history as the first new emote extension to
succeed at breaking into the scene and also stir up the twitch space by expanding on the whole idea
of an extension and for them it's worked quite well i don't believe better tv will ever fully die
but the stunts performed by night have truly put a stain on the entire legacy of better tv
und benutze den chat im browser
lass mich raten das ist ein indisches video oder you must need to watch
das klingt schon irgendwie
wie sas
oder china chinesen das kann natürlich auch sein ja auch möglich auch möglich
ich glaube es ist bettgetime oder nicht
wie seht ihr das sieht es sieht nach 22 uhr 8 aus
das heißt sieht nicht nur nach 22 uhr 8 aus sieht nach 22 ist auch 22 uhr 8
musst du morgen arbeiten ja ich muss montags nicht arbeiten freitags muss ich arbeiten
und das wird beim neuen arbeitgeber auch so sein
und morgen fahre ich sogar noch mal nach frankfurt
um zu checken ob ich irgendwas vergessen habe im chat post jam
ja
ja welche denn
ich sehe keine er macht sommer ist das wurde chain law gebannt das ist ein neuer account vom
chain law hier das muss ich jetzt mal überprüfen
okay nee du bist kein account von chain law du bist 2013 gejohnt und bist seit 2017 am
starten hast über 1000 nachrichten geschrieben nee okay du bist nicht du bist nicht 2.0 ich ich
glaube ich habe dich auch schon der chain law ist normalerweise der einzige dieses ausrufe
zeichen frage sinnlos spammt
wo ist er eigentlich da habe ich jetzt den letzten zwei streams nicht gesehen normalerweise ist
der immer am start und spammt irgendwelche sinnlosen dinger rum oder oder postet irgendwelche
monka toss subreddits und sowas oder sowas ja
okay leute wir sehen uns ist den macht es gut zu